[موسيقى]
يطالب بعض الناس بمناعة القطيع
للمساعدة في إبطاء انتشار فيروس
كورونا ، النظرية هي أنك تسمح للفيروس
بالمرور عبر السكان
الناجين دون رادع يطورون أجسامًا مضادة
ضد العدوى في المستقبل ومن المفترض أن
يصبحوا
محصنين في النهاية بحيث يصبح الكثير من الناس
محصنين  يصبح الانتشار من شخص لآخر
غير مرجح
، يصفه جميع المراسلين الطبيين الرئيسيين في CNN
بأنه استراتيجية رهيبة
مع مناعة القطيع فقط لإعطائك
فكرة والناس يعرفون هذا بشكل عام
الآن
ولكن ما الذي يعنيه ذلك يعني
أن 60 إلى 70 بالمائة من السكان
يصبح مصابًا ،
وهذا عدد كبير بما يكفي بحيث
يخلقون في الأساس قطيعًا من الحماية
حول أشخاص آخرين ، نعلم أنه مع
حوالي 10
من البلاد التي أصيبت بالعدوى
، توفي 216000 شخص تقريبًا ، لذا قم فقط
بحساب ما سيحدث
إذا بدأت في مضاعفة ذلك  ضرب ستة
أو سبعة ، هذا هو المكان الذي بدأت
فيه الوصول إلى 1.4 إلى 2
مليون من الأشخاص الذين قد يكونون p
يموت محتمل وربما كما قال الدكتور هاسيلشتاين
كل عام أيضًا لا نعرف إلى متى
تستمر المناعة من الالتهابات الطبيعية ،
فقد يستغرق الأمر عدة أشهر ولكن ربما
ليس موسمًا كاملاً ،
إنها استراتيجية مروعة